since release CS2 has felt kind of rough
for a couple of reasons I'm
blind what is this spray welcome to CS2
beta oh my God so
basic terrorists win but among CS2
issues is the fact that compared to csgo
the op has felt sort of
off almost C I
think he's he's he's I swear the op is
off by a millimeter I'm telling you bro
just wait for like one of these Co opers
to say
something oh my God up he not good
they're a whole different Beast going
through the upper bracket and oh on the
line where that bullet go huh the op was
at one point so bad that even the best
player in the world world was
considering a roll swap but is the
iconic sniper rifle actually worse in
CS2 or is there something going on
behind the scenes that's affecting the
game's Gunplay as a whole yet again same
as in the piss around that op oh the op
is difficult to
use you're just not good
[Applause]
enough all right so before we start
talking about the off in CS2 I need you
to check out our new merch collection
like our onward and forward te over at
shop. thescore.com okay so as I've said
and as I'm sure you already know the op
in Counter Strike is very iconic it's
been core to Counter Strike for nearly
25 years and over the past decade shaped
an entire generation of csgo players who
showed the world just how strong it
could be in the right hands kenes stuck
in the site finding Mo that's brilliant
and kenes again up close oh my goodness
Kenny s the no scope on the third this
guy is absolutely insane thanks to
players like JW and kenes valve targeted
the op with a major Nerf back in 2015
lowering the scoped movement value this
was a massive Nerf that hit certain
players harder than others specifically
t- sided opers and opers who played with
a very hyper aggressive play style but
over time players got used to the new OP
mechanics and it remained a core part of
the game throughout the latter half of
csgo's lifespan a new generation of
young Stars proved that they could still
do some serious damage with the big
green yeah was at least jumping I think
so yeah yeah nasty stuff but simple's
going to get himself
oh
that is something special for years the
op remained relatively untouched until
late 2022 when valve decided to reduce
its magazine size from 10 bullets to
five this meant that opers couldn't spam
smokes or walls as frequently and had to
be very conscious of how many bullets
were in the mag come of the later stages
of a round still this didn't hit nearly
as hard as 2015's Nerf which basically
changed everything players continued to
do their thing with the op and when CS2
was announced earlier this year it
introduced volumetric smokes prettier
graphics and sub tick updates the op did
receive a Nerf in the form of visible
bullet tracers but nobody really knew
how much this would affect the meta when
players finally got their hands on CS2
however they immediately noticed that
something about the Gunplay just felt
off
I'm what is this spray your shots in
this game
bro
random bro Arch oh Lord dude I'm going
to lose my now there were definitely a
lot of players myself included who were
complaining about how sprays felt back
when CS2 first launched but the op was
one of the biggest points of discussion
I
think he's he's he's I swear the op is
off by a millimeter I'm telling you bro
just wait for like one of these Pro
opers to say
something oh my God op he not good
they're a whole different Beast going
through the upper bracket and oh on the
line where' that bullet go
huh okay hey hey somebody get valve on
the phone what you see is what you get
aside from the bullet tracers players
began complaining that the op just felt
more difficult to use especially when
flicking to targets and as someone who
oped a lot in csgo I definitely
experienced my fair share of this but
why did it feel like this well part of
the answer goes way over my head I mean
there's a reason I used the skill Cannon
to begin with so I'm going to bring in
Colton to help us explain what was going
on behind the scenes in CS2 and now the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about hold up we let Dimitri out of the
house and we set them up in the Swanky
new studio maybe we can upgrade this
studio next no oh all right yeah that's
cool uh oh yeah sub tick I talked about
it a bit in a video earlier this year
but since then players have done a ton
of research so let's talk about it over
the past few months a lot of people have
attributed CS 2's problems to input lag
and this video from qk Norris back in
September convinced even more people
that it was the reason that the gun play
felt weird but the community and qk
Norris recognized some problems with his
initial testing namely that he was using
the glock's muzzle flash to test latency
and not just that he also compared
inputs from csgo's 128 tick servers to
CS2 64 tick servers an important
distinction because on 64 tick servers
you you can experience up to 16
milliseconds of extra input lag versus 8
milliseconds on 128 tick a couple of
days later Reddit user towel pitiful
8354 posted this slow motion footage of
an OP firing at zero ping in CS2 to help
demonstrate how sub tick actually works
you'll notice that they click their
Mouse then quickly flick to the right
but when the muzzle flashes the bullet
still goes where they were aiming at the
time of the click I'm going to go ahead
and flick my wrist extremely fast to the
right and click once my mouse gets to
the edge of my mouse
pad uh you can see that the muzzle flash
went off pretty close to the ladder over
here but as I painfully turn
around there it is an impact in the
filing cabinet where I was
aiming on the previous frame so let's
switch gears over to csgo instead as you
can see here we get almost precisely the
opposite Behavior where shots are
registering with my mouse flick included
What's Happening Here is the game only
knows the position your Crosshair is at
each time a frame is rendered so when
you click your mouse in between rendered
frames the game has to make a choice in
csgo that choice was that it would
register your bullet path on the next
frame that occurred in CS2 however it
decides to register your bullet path
using the previous frames positional
data qk Norris after a lot of testing
boiled down the real culprit of cs2s
mouse input feeling quote unquote
delayed to the slower and more
inconsistent frame render times when it
comes down to shooting however that
subtle change from calculating bullet
trajectory on the next frame to the
previous frame is enough to really mess
with your muscle memory so in reality
what your game Saw when you clicked is
actually what you get even if your PC
hasn't drawn the frame yet maybe that's
what valve meant when they said that
luckily valve has made more improvements
to spraying and oping in the past couple
of months by making muzzle flashes
render on the following frame similar to
csgo which made the Gunplay feel
considerably better or so I'm told
reducing any system latency will also
help improve this but since players
spent a decade getting used to the op in
CS go it's just going to come down to
time for them to adjust to the op in CS2
and that was the guy who actually knows
what he's talking about okay so it seems
that the op is basically working as
intended and perhaps we all just need to
get used to the feel of the new game but
that doesn't change the fact that it's
not quite as overpowered as it was in
CSO as players are getting used to the
new shooting mechanics they've realized
that the brutal peers of advantage in
CS2 makes it feel even harder to flick
to moving targets and because of this
sometimes holding angles in CS2 just
feels awful I'm
done SI St players have also crucially
noticed that the op now becomes
inaccurate when you take damage which
might explain this Mony clip that you
saw at the beginning of this video he
might not have been scammed and perhaps
the aim punch that he experienced before
shooting his op caused the inaccuracy
but regardless of everything new that's
going on behind the scenes some players
have really been struggling to get used
to these changes even the goat simple
said that he considered swapping roles
because the op just doesn't feel as
impactful as it used to be and it
doesn't help that the game is also
switched to mr12 fewer rounds probably
means fewer Ops and it's true that the
economy is probably still in need of
some tweaking but right now that's just
how the game plays the op is not going
to be backed like CS go so you need to
to find new thing to do new Peak maybe
new thing to do with your team with over
the op so when you manage to think like
this yeah with everything behind it you
can do everything you want that's why
after see I was like playing a lot of fa
playing trying to think about what can I
do with my op more maybe and look if
some of the best players in the world
are out there proving that the Ops still
has a place in The Meta maybe the jury
is still out on the severity of all of
this even though the Big Green might
feel a tad worse than CS2 you can still
make it work and who knows maybe a new
generation will come along and show us
what's possible with the franchise's
most iconic gun all over again it's one
round in it and broy is full set once
again down the B it's a good hold from
twist needed that one bro's done it
again multi kill close coures comat
oring thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring the notification Bell
for Unique bite-size videos you won't
find anywhere else hit us up on our
Twitter Instagram Facebook and Tik
[Music]
Tok